[Applause]
they they i was just in l.a
from here and it was like yes i don't
know i met someone
and they're like uh i said i'm you know
they're like where do you live i go
nashville and they were like oh so
you're like an anti-vaxxer
like and they're kind of joking but
they're not and you go yeah yeah you
don't want to see what the problem is
you just do you know how crazy that is
yeah yeah hey you're just going you
don't know me at all
you're just going because i said i'm
from yeah tennessee yeah yeah and you
immediately say like i'm gonna eat now
that being
said no the north but that being said
real quick like you are an animal
don't be bringing your dumb vaccines all
over my arm dude
where are these vaccines coming from
dude i don't know who this guy is
someone said they were walking around uh
walmart
and like they were trying to get because
they said yeah i'm sure they read this
somewhere who knows if this is even true
but they go
they're walking around walmart in like
uh the south and just being like hey
we'll give you your vaccine you can do
it right now yeah and then people are
like saying no
to it you're like yeah man dude if i was
shopping at walmart and a guy walked up
with a needle and was like hey man do
you mind if we just do this i'd be like
no
yeah like you're just out of there's no
contact i'm not in a doctor's office
you're just some random guy named pedro
walking i'm buying flip-flops and then
you're like
my glasses from walmart i'd be passing
that section like who the [ __ ] is
getting glasses
so so are are you vaxxed or not so i
have a weird
oh boy let's go they were right they're
100
right about you no i don't know if i
would want
here's i always have a weird thing i
don't know if i want to say it because i
don't
like i don't like when people show
pictures of them getting vaccinated yeah
yeah yeah so i don't ever be an
influence on
anybody getting one or not getting one
yeah i'm not saying i did one way or the
other yeah
i'm not even saying i wouldn't ever tell
you but it's like
why do you need to know if i like that's
not i just want to know if that guy was
racist and right
uh or stereotypical and right yeah so
it's like uh
well then it's the opposite of
everything i just said yeah
what a piece of [ __ ] to just judge me
based on how i talk and how i look
i don't want to tell them yeah i mean
you just told everybody
if what i mean i think we know no you
don't because i
also the way that you walked in here i
know and i know which one it is see
you're doing this
you can't get that you can't get that
new york out of it it's pfizer bro
oh you know you're a pfizer dude you're
a [ __ ] pfizer dude
are you sure that's pretty good i guess
i've had uh i have i've had one
oh you just gone i've only done one
you're just going half in
well wait are you really fizer did i get
that right yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
amazing
uh i only did yeah because i left and so
i couldn't do the second one
uh so the plan is to do the second when
i get back i'll be honest with you
though that first one
that you do you want to be like that's
good right like we're good yeah i think
you're good like the second one
everybody's like dude i get so sick
every second when you're like
why are we how many do we got to do yeah
it's like you do wonder that
you're like can i do but yeah mark's an
anti-vaxxer he's not doing it that's not
true
you are the most anti-vaxxer compared to
no
no no no no no yes he is he is anti-x
bro
alexander have actually blackpopped he's
not getting it and he's forging
documents he said he was going to forge
the documents using
mine i i'm going to give him five
i'm just reluctant and i'm gonna get it
when it's inconvenient right
right the only reason i got is because
my girl signed me up we came down here
with antibodies and we were like [ __ ] it
let's go
yeah like everybody here got corona yeah
and we're like that's that's
the vaccine that's the vaccine yeah you
get it and then that's the same
but do you feel like you can't like say
these things you feel like you'll piss
off your audience no no
no not make them mad i don't uh
the audacity of like when people like
either have
whatever platform makes me furious
someone says they have a platform
dude they got to talk nate land is a
platform dude but i know but i don't use
it for
a platform i usually should dude i've
watched you talk about teddy roosevelt
and and
you know just talking about nothing dude
we're just making dumb jokes it's it's
but i'm saying i don't want to be a
platformer propping up these
conservative presidents
bro when yeah was teddy roosevelt i
don't know
actually he was democrat like tax the
[ __ ] out of it i think everybody would i
don't know anything about
history they're uh but it's
the idea of when everybody says they're
like they're
you know you got a platform you got to
use it you're like how about you don't
have to use it
yeah i don't have to use my platform i
didn't go to college dude i barely met
at high school you don't need anything
from me
i don't know what i'm doing like i don't
you should never listen to me
right and these celebrities like when
they think they have to
surprise me furiously tell someone
you're ready don't get me started
do you know how hard it is you're an
anti-platformer i'm an anti-platformer
yeah that's exactly yeah that's what the
podcast was started
we talked about we're just trying to be
funny that's great and it's like
it's super funny it's in my stand-up i
love weber by the way
huh weber oh aaron yeah he's great he
opened for us in uh
nashville oh yeah yeah yeah and he's
just super funny it's
who's the other guy brian bates he came
out with me for a lot and everybody
calls them like
uh some reason that listeners started
calling them names they call them like
bacon bits and breakfast and correct
they want combos what did i say he has a
spokesperson in it yeah yeah yeah he
could he could definitely be a
spokesperson yeah yeah
for breakfast for breakfast the meal the
general the general movie i mean that's
like yeah
you know that was teddy roosevelt was
the teddy bear is named after him
which we talked about which how crazy is
that that's all you know
a teddy bear is there's not like i don't
even know the name before that
right and so they made the teddy bear
and that's in honor of him
but he wasn't even like cuddles he was a
bad ass mother [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah i mean i
wasn't there
it wasn't my decision right but yeah you
know act like i was a part of this
choice like i gotta defend it it's not
information though it's
it is they that's what they did in honor
of him right
but i'm saying it's uh teddy bears like
that's how you describe that thing
yeah yeah yeah like that's about the
highest honor you could get
to have a stuffed you know any store
yeah you don't you know any store and
you got like a you have
any teddy bears yeah and it's not a
specific thing it's in general
mmm yeah yeah pretty nice yeah yeah yeah
yeah now you said you don't know
anything about anything no
what do you know the most about a lot of
things okay
and no uh
uh oh i don't know i don't know sports
sports fan yeah i'm a big sports fan
golf like uh that kind of thing you were
getting into those like
like celebrity golf tournaments yeah
early
yeah i'm trying yeah i'm getting in a
little bit more now now but now it makes
sense
yeah but i think it was like you were in
early and i was like oh
[ __ ] like who is that guy
you were golfing with like famous people
yeah and i was like oh [ __ ] is nate
blowing the [ __ ] up
yeah yeah it started when you're uh when
you when you're the celebrity in a group
at the beginning you're you're a big
disappointment to that group
like they come up dude and they're like
what's up who we got yeah
yeah yeah yeah they hand you the clock
has that really happen uh you gotta you
gotta go put on a show like you're like
they're like what do you do i'm not like
i'm a comedian and you gotta bring
oh you gotta be [ __ ] funny bro you
gotta be so
in your but you wanted them you're like
well i don't know why y'all pay a little
more money and you get up a little like
you pay for it you don't need more of
this [ __ ] charity
that you'd be doing with papa john's
yeah instead you got this
you got me
you